the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
what part we feed my brother coming back
from a coma bouncing back he has cancer
so I mean he nearly died and now he's
coming back I mean his hairs back so it
looks normal again
and I mean so he will take a little
brother again and I see them come back
to life and I see him kind of dying come
back so it's almost like the gift of
life
I seen it my woman's belly only because
she's seven months pregnant right now
because we've been through so much and
this is our first child so we excited we
had a few losses and this one stuck so
[Music]
not to be like a real side but it was
like when my mom was dying and we are
all in hospice and we would just all had
this song playing like my whole family
was in the room and all of us just like
sadly wept and then we all just like
looked at each other like no one said
anything but we all just like understood
like you know what I mean like it was
like almost time I saw it in a dream
it's this room that had a whole ocean
inside of it and swimming in the ocean
like contained in one room I don't know
there's something so small and big about
it that no one else will be able to
visit that place I feel what I felt
swimming there but it was just so
beautiful
the sunlight hitting the pond Golden
Gate Park during a golden hour because
it looked exactly like a Claude Monet
painting and it was just like I don't
know it was just picturesque like I was
just so content when I saw it most
beautiful thing I've ever seen is a
total solar eclipse with my husband in
our backyard for more than two minutes
and just getting to see colors I've
never seen shades I've never seen and
just getting to do it all from home it's
one of the most amazing things ever just
life for people buildings the fact that
if you're standing inside of a building
it's just like some
without some ideas that you're standing
inside of I could go on and on but
basically that's the general gist so
life is on the night sky in Joshua Tree
and seeing stars that I have never seen
before it made me just feel like I had
missed something that they were there
all along and I had never gotten the
chance to see them I like language and
culture I think that's pretty beautiful
because it's like I don't know it just
it's it's a way people express
themselves and people can like go in
between cultures this why I'm here in
San Francisco is to experience the
culture here and I just I think it's
beautiful and amazing
and wonderful I actually grew up deaf
but I didn't know I was deaf until I was
like 12
so I whenever I did discover it I took
sign language in high school and that's
whenever I like started started
discovering my my own personal culture
and I think that might be buying also
involved with loving other people's
cultures because I got to discover my
own kind of I wasn't born deaf my ears I
didn't my ears gave out and I did have
ear drums for a while for about ten
years maybe my mom thought I was like
selective hearing like when she called
me she was like oh she's just ignoring
me being an awful child no I actually
honestly probably like these guys faces
when we hang out honestly
these guys are like my best friends you
know we grew up right here in this
neighborhood we've been hanging out for
like 10 years you know my friends
[Music]
the most beautiful thing you've ever
seen it has different colors it's like a
rainbow everyone dies
that say it's right
myself I mean I'm just really kind to
people I tried to be kind to people so I
think that's what makes me beautiful
the first time I saw Roger Federer's
backhand I just thought it was so
beautiful and efficient and perfect and
yeah Roger Federer's backhand is the
most beautiful thing I've ever seen as a
chaise if I say this with your
girlfriend
[Music]
your girlfriend make me feel like I'm
about to eat a giant full-on photo like
that excitement you know just
when you've got to take that first bite
and excitement oh Christ
yeah I remember when I was born just
coming out of the womb seeing that light
for the first time it was kind of like a
beautiful moment that I'll never forget
and a Green Day concert unfortunately
the day my ex-wife said yes when I asked
her to marry me the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen probably whatever I've
been up snowboarding and you see a snow
dog which is like the wind blowing off
the top of a peak and the snow makes
like millions of rainbows on the sky we
have a nice blue powder blue sky brisk
air and little baby rainbows everywhere
from the snow snow breeze
I think that's pretty beautiful it was
my friend giving birth to her baby there
were five of us co-workers and we all
watched her give birth at first we were
like yeah because some really gross came
out and then we saw the baby crowning
and we're all in on it was all ladies
they were like
and that was the most beautiful thing
there was big emotion like emotional
sadness joy all in one because I've
always wanted a child in me I wasn't
blessed in this life to happen
watching someone playing music and
specifically it was this girl at this
festival and she had a mandolin and at
the time I didn't know what it was but
like when I watched her play it so
passionately I just like fell in love it
was like the day I fell in love with
music it made me feel like me was like
so much more to life that I didn't know
about and she opened this door and my
life forever changed after that day I
never knew I didn't know of the feeling
of like connecting with the instrument
expressing yourself and like what that
does to other people
Beyonce a concert my first time I went
like tickets over the phone and she just
walked on stage she had like this gold
like outfit
that's like the most beautiful open
fields like just sky open fields no
files in the sky that's beautiful to me
I guess it's just like the distance just
like how far like there's just it just
seems like miles and miles of just open
land and like I don't know you know like
your mind kind of runs free so you think
about just running through and how far
you can went there and stuff like that
so I guess that's I know it feels more
beautiful I was on a train in India
going from New Delhi to the Himalayas
and we got off the train and we hopped
in these little kind of like raggedy
cars and I was with all my friends and
we turned this one corner around the
mountain and I just the glimpse of like
the Himalayan peaks it was just
absolutely incredible and the Sun was
just kind of rising and it just like it
took us so long to get to that moment so
it just made it all that more special
but I just got the first glimpse of the
Himalayas it's just absolutely beautiful
my mom passed away and have a very vivid
memory of my dad stepping into the I
believe was the Blackfoot River and he
sprinkled her ashes into the water it
was one of the bodies of waters that she
requested them her ass
I haven't thought about it probably
since that day so
thank you for asking me this question
my mom she's beautiful beautiful human
being she took care of me all my life
single mom
shoutout to my mom I love you and I'm
always be here for you the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen is anyone
with dark hair and light blue eyes it's
like the way it looks it reminds me of
my mom oh my mom when I went to Canada
recently if she's looking at like the
ocean and she's like this is pretty dank
and I thought she was pretty day she
looked really nice she's just really a
beautiful thing I've ever seen I'll have
to say is my mother
sure
and all the good feelings
every possible way that's good
and when you down she puts your
affection love
so so much your mama you know like the
first person you saw when you came out
and then that beauty cannot be beaten
you know when you say the most beautiful
thing ever is first thing I think about
it
hey everyone quick announcement have new
idea for an episode and it bolts you
guys so if you're interested people on
Instagram and wait for posts that will
explain everything that's pretty much it
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you this Thursday